[Musik]
richtig bekannt wurde sie erst im herbst
2009 als ihr der literatur nobelpreis
zugesprochen wurde ihr einer deutschen
geboren im banat in rumänien deren
sprache als präzise und dringlich
beschrieben wird deren werk als
literatur der quälenden fragen höchste
beachtung hat herta müllers
terminkalender ist seitdem voll in ihrem
ersten großen fernsehauftritt nach der
nobelpreisverleihung erzählt herta
müller jetzt von ihrem bewegten leben
zwischen rumänien und deutschland
spricht über vergangenheit und die
vielschichtige gegenwart aber auch von
ihrer freundschaft zum schriftsteller
oskar pastior über den jüngst bekannt
wurde dass auch er unter dem druck des
rumänischen geheimdienstes securitas
zusammengebrochen war
juri steiner befragt herta müller seinem
ersten gespräch in der sternstunde
philosophie sehr geehrte frau müller
herzlich willkommen in der sternstunde
philosophie weiter sehr dass sie hier
sind vor knapp einem jahr haben sie den
literatur nobelpreis bekommen was haben
sie mit diesem preis gemacht und was hat
er mit ihnen gemacht
naja ich was habe ich damit gemacht
ich habe damit das gemacht was man mir
verlangt hat das heißt ich wusste nach
stockholm
ich musste ihn entgegennehmen und danach
habe ich ziemlich viele veranstaltungen
macht so wie jetzt auch und was er mit
mir gemacht hat also mit mir persönlich
hat er glaube ich nicht viel gemacht
weil ich das für etwas ganz
selbstverständliches einordne obwohl ich
weiß es ist ein ganz großes glück
aber ich glaube ich habe mich innerlich
dadurch nicht beeindrucken lassen
ich versuche das immer auseinander zu
halten ich sage da sind meine bücher das
andere ich als person und das eine hat
mit dem anderen nur bedingt zu tun und
es ist die veranstaltungen das alles das
ist es ist wie ein wie ein job es ist
ein anderer job als der mit dem man
eigentlich sonst zu tun hat mein mann
mein selbstverständnis ist am
schreibtisch zu sitzen und die dinge mit
mir allein auszumachen
und wenn ich in der öffentlichkeit bin
dann ist das ein anderer beruf und er
gehört halt dazu und das ist es die
dankesrede in stockholm
versprechen sie sprachen sie von einem
taschentuch als als wie ein leitmotiv
für diese rede was hat es mit diesem
taschentuch auf sich
naja ich hab halt überlegt vielleicht
auch weil es ja was keine taschentücher
mehr gibt weil wir ja fast alle nur noch
die papiertaschentücher benutzen und ich
habe überlegt wie wichtig taschentücher
seinerzeit waren und dass das
taschentuch in fast allen
lebenssituationen eine ganz verschiedene
unterschiedliche rolle spielt und in wie
vielen dass es so wandelbar ist in wie
vielen situationen ist zu etwas anderen
benutzt werden kann und das ist im
grunde eine ein sehr wichtiger
gegenstand den wir fast gar nicht mehr
gebrauchen
aber es war auch eine sehr persönliche
geschichte damit verknüpft mit ihrer
mutter mit dem kind das immer meine
mutter war ja fast immer auf dem feld
und hat gearbeitet meine eltern meine
großeltern auch und so auf dem dorf hat
man sich ja nicht den ganzen tag um die
kinder gekümmert so wie ich das zum
beispiel heute sehe also man war sich
zum großen teil selbst überlassen
man wurde im grunde genommen was ich gar
nicht so schlecht finde wie ein fast wie
ein erwachsener mensch behandelt also
mann hatte trotz früh verantwortung zu
übernehmen
es gab verschiedene dinge die man im
haus arbeiten musste und wenn ich
morgens zur schule gehen und meine
mutter fragte er ob ich ein taschen tun
habe das war fast immer die einzige
situation wo ich gedacht habe
sie kümmert sich doch um mich oder es
ist eine art von zuwendung es war fast
wie eine zärtlichkeit und wo ich auch
immer dachte wenn ich das taschentuch
extra nicht hatte dass ich noch einmal
zurückgehen und es dann nehme und von
diesem gedanken aus ist mir dann ein
gefallen
in wie vielen situationen das
taschentuch eigentlich eine rolle spielt
ja auch in der familie
diese ganze taschentuch
geschichte dass jeder in der familie hat
seine eigenen taschen tücher die männer
taschentücher die frauen taschentücher
dann gab es die kinder taschentücher und
wie die dann in den in der schublade
gestapelt waren dann gab es die
taschentücher für werktags dann gab die
sonntags taschentücher und wenn man dann
mal ein taschentuch gefunden hat und das
hatte also dieses taschentuch war hat
eine rolle gespielt und in wie vielen
situationen auch als kind wenn einmal
hat man gemeint dann war man verschnupft
dann hatte man sich das knie oder den
ellenbogen aufgeschlagen dann hat man am
bahnhof gefunden wenn jemand mit dem zug
weg vor
dann hat man toten das taschentuch aufs
gesicht gelegt in der stadt habe ich das
zum beispiel sehr oft gesehen was das
für das klima wenn leute auf der straße
gestorben sind wenn sie umgefallen waren
und es waren fremde und es ging in
passanten vorbei und dann haben
passanten immer diesem toten taschentuch
aus der tasche gezogen und das
taschentuch aufs gesicht gelegt das war
so wie der erste schutz vor vor der vor
der umgebung und das fand ich immer eine
sehr anrührende geste aber es gehört
also zum alltag in romanes mein chef der
straße gestanden
das ist halt hier und da passiert in
rumänien hat man natürlich viele es gab
auch ja es gab viel mehr katastrophen
auf der straße weil auch die armut
spielte deine rolle
es wurde auf der straße viel mehr gelebt
es wurde auf der straße viel mehr zum
beispiel getrunken
es sind oft alkoholiker auf der straße
gestorben oder einfach menschen
umgefallen weil die ärztliche versorgung
nicht so man ist nicht ständig zum arzt
gegangen und hat vorsorge und jeder
wusste jetzt müsste man das oder das man
ist in oman oft unerwartet an
kleinigkeiten gestorben unter anderem
auch auf der straße
was mich unternehmen würde auch der
nobelpreis der ihnen überreicht wurde
bedeutet sich dadurch auch eine art von
verantwortung es sein kann ist eine last
sein
es ist keine last
also es hat mich eigentlich an den preis
am meisten gefreut dass dieses thema
jetzt diktatur und die ganzen verbrechen
der diktaturen der osteuropäischen oder
der diktaturen überhaupt ich meine
wirkung genau so gut an gottesstaaten
denken an den iran zum beispiel oder ein
afrikanischer diktaturen die ganz anders
geartet sind ein militärdiktaturen im
grunde genommen passiert ja in allen
diktaturen mit dem einzelnen menschen
dasselbe dass der einzelne nichts zählt
dass ein menschenleben nichts sehe dass
es keine freie meinungsäußerung geben
darf dass das denken an und für sich
verboten ist das ganoven hafte
diktatoren oder familienclans sich den
ganzen staat unter den nagel reißen
dass sie das die ganze bevölkerung zu
einer geisel machen ihres wohlstands und
ihrer korruption und ihres macht hungers
und dass dieses thema durch diesen preis
weil es in meinen büchern ja
ausschließlich fast darum geht dass
dieses thema durch diesen preis ins ins
gespräch gekommen ist und das ist das
darauf jetzt auch der blick geworfen
wird und ich glaube man weiß auch heute
noch viel zu wenig oder man ist sich
noch viel zu wenig bewusst wie viele
verbrechen zum beispiel diese
osteuropäischen sozialistischen
diktaturen verursacht haben
das wird erst im laufe der jahre
wahrscheinlich langsam langsam zusammen
addiert werden können
und dann dann werden wir ziemlich
erschreckend
also die die bescheid wissen die aus
diesen zusammenhängen kommen die wissen
das schon
aber die anderen die gott sei dank nicht
in solchen zusammenhängen leben mussten
dann ist das glaube ich noch nicht so
sehr bewusst sehen sie den aktuellen
friedensnobelpreisträger liu xiabo in
einem ähnlichen kontext wie sie fühlen
sie sich im verband können sie sich ja
das finde ich auch ganz großartig dass
man sich dafür entschieden hat ihm
diesen friedensnobelpreis zu geben und
dass das auch wieder so ein zeichen ist
und dass ich meine das sagen ja auch die
leute in china die dissidenten und auch
andere dass man dadurch auch die
chinesen den chinesen einen spiegel
vorhält und wir sehen ja wie sich jener
verhält nachdem dieser preis jetzt
vergeben wurde
dass dieser mensch elf jahre gefängnis
die wissen auch nicht genau wofür
erschütterung der grundordnung der
gesellschaft ich bitte sie
was soll das und dass man über schuld er
findet um leute und das sind ja meistens
die die in texten die sensibelsten die
dann ins gefängnis müssen und die die
korrupten und die sich die macht unter
den nagel reißen die die sitzen dann in
der regierung und das finger auch sieht
dass die weltöffentlichkeit hier nicht
nachgibt und dass sie mit ihrer haltung
sich jetzt buchstäblich blamieren
auch durch dieses trotzen und greifern
und auch auffordern andere sollten sich
nicht beteiligen und das ist auch
schrecklich dass dann 17 länder sagen
sie gehen da nicht hin
einschließlich serbien oder solche
länder die ja meinen sie könnten
demnächst in die eu und dass das zeigt
ja auch wieder sehr viel also durch
diesen preis ist auch wieder ein spiegel
gesetzt worden in ganz verschiedene
richtungen und es ist für den
verbraucher sehr wichtig und das wird ja
doch folgen haben denn ich glaube die
chinesen können sich nicht ewig mit
diesem 1
kein system und diesen diktatorischen
methoden an der macht halten ihre
wirtschaft schreitet fort und hier ist
wirtschaftsaufschwung und auf der
anderen seite nur knüppel und ich glaube
dass das geht nicht auf die dauer und
das sollten diese herren wahrscheinlich
auch mal werken und ich glaube sie
merken es auch denn diese dieses rabiate
dass sie jetzt an den tag legen ist
natürlich auch ein beweis dafür dass sie
sich ihre selbstverständlichkeit nicht
mehr ganz sicher sind
ich hatte noch einen auftritt zusammen
mit dem chinesischen künstler ai weiwei
und der lit.cologne letztes jahr war das
für sie von bedeutung zu sehen wie sich
die themen wiederholen wie sie sich
schneiden wie sie sich in anderen kultur
kontexten behaupten auch diese
brutalität von den schienen
ja es ist ja immer das selbe ich weiß
wenn ich mit solchen leuten rede wir
können unsere erfahrungen austauschen
wir machen die gleichen erfahrungen als
als individuen als einzelner menschen
bei ai weiweis jetzt auch eine kamera
vor dem haus gehabt erzählt dort sitzt
einer im bus der tag und nacht schaut
jeder jeden schritt den er tut
damals kurz davor hatten sie ihn
zusammengeschlagen
es ist nur in china zurzeit eine sehr
gemischte situation einerseits lässt man
ihn reisen und er wird als muster
dissident eigentlich hat er eine gewisse
narrenfreiheit aber wenn man dann lust
hat wieder hin zurückzupfeifen
dann geht man wieder ganz brutal vor und
schlägt ihn zusammen
also es ist eine undurchschaubare bild
kurses nicht mehr geradlinig wie es
seinerzeit in den diktaturen in den
osteuropäischen aber auch in den in der
chinesischen diktatur war weil man sich
das nicht mehr leisten kann offenbar
aber in den lücken tut man wird man dann
doch wieder brutal nicht und fällt
wieder auf den ganz ganz alten
statistischen grunde statistischen
muster zurück
und diese erfahrungen über die kann man
mit solchen leuten natürlich reden in
dem sinn kommen wir nicht aus demselben
land auch nicht aus derselben kultur
aber alle diktatoren sind dieselbe
kultur
das heißt sie sind dieselbe und kultur
und insofern hat man immer die gleichen
dinge erlebt ja ich möchte gerne ein
bisschen auf ihre biografie zu sprechen
kommen wenn man wenn man ihre sehr
berührenden starken texte liest hat man
immer das gefühl dass man auch das kind
mitliest mitspielt und ihre kindheit
glaube ich war sehr wichtig das ist ein
allgemeinplatz aber ich würde gerne die
sind über mit skidorf sprechen mit ihnen
ja kleines dorf das waren ich glaube
etwas über 400 häuser und dann waren die
familienstrukturen waren großfamilie
das heißt in jedem haus lebten drei
generationen also kinder eltern
großeltern und das dorf war also wie ein
schacht auf einem schachbrett
symmetrisch gegliedert hauptstraße und
dann gingen immer seitlich die
nebenstraßen ab und die wurden dann
aufgefangen von wieder pannen laufend in
strassen also es war so ein viereck und
es war ein sehr kleines dorf jeder
kannte jeden und anonymität gab es also
nicht und alle waren bauern fast alle
von den männern sind einige dann jeden
tag in die stadt gependelt haben in
fabriken gearbeitet oder waren
handwerker oder schneider oder friseur
und in der stadt und die der großteil
der leute waren aber bauern und es gab
eine schule und die kinder aus den
nachbargemeinden kamen in das dorf zur
schule und die anderen dörfer und das
war vielleicht auch sehr wichtig waren
verschiedene also es gab immer zehn
kilometer für kilometer das war alles
sehr nahe aber aus der damaligen sicht
war das sehr weit also zwölf kilometer
war die erste stadt war busch
das war ein kleiner kurort ein kurbad
und dann gab es aber ein slowakisches
dorf dann gab es ein ungarisches dorf
ein rumänisches dorf ein deutsches dorf
und die sachen haben sich eigentlich
nicht gemischt
also jede minorität oder auch die
rumänien wohnten in ihrem eigenen dorf
hatten ihre eigenen ihre eigene tracht
ihre eigene sprache ihre eigene feier
eigenen feiertage und man hat im grunde
genommen kaum voneinander notiz genommen
man ist hier und da männer einmal wusste
indem man dem dorf ist jetzt ein
feiertag ist man im sommer dazu fuß hin
gegangen hat sich ein bisschen dort
herumgetrieben und aber sonst hat man
eigentlich fast nichts miteinander zu
tun
und dann fand ich das so illusorisch als
sich aus so mehr nach deutschland kam
als ich dieses multikulturelle gehört
habe und wie man sich das vorstellt und
also aus dem was ich von so von dieser
von rumänien weiß wo ja so viele
nationalitäten wohnen über jahrhunderte
habe ich mir nie vorstellen können wie
das sein soll wenn wenn das alles sich
zusammen tun soll und in welchem maß ist
es dann assimilation oder ist das
anpassung und in welcher form und wer an
wen und wie viel zu wem also ich hab das
immer für sehr illusorisch gehalten
sondern ich habe immer gedacht dass das
einzig praktikable ist auch im
deutschland oder wahrscheinlich auch in
der schweiz oder in österreich
das ist man lebt nebeneinander und man
lässt sich in ruhe und soweit es nötig
es geht man aufeinander zu und
selbstverständlich lebt man mit
vorurteilen
wenn die nur wer wahl sind dann gehören
sie zum alltag und schwierig ist es wenn
es zu aggressionen führen und das
entsteht aber nicht wenn man
nebeneinander her ist entsteht das nicht
so sie sind ja ziemlich in delitzsch auf
der einen seite ist ein bisschen wie
land trotzdem haben sie wenn sie sagen
man lässt sich in ruhe ist diese ruhe ja
auch unheimlich also hier schreibt nach
über tabus dies gab die vergangenheit
dies nicht gar die beschädigung live
da waren natürlich das leben war dort
sehr
es war so alles war eigentlich geregelt
also mann lebte in einer 1 in einem
einzigen gesetz und das war natürlich
kein geschriebenes gesetz aber es waren
die feiertage
es war jeder wusste wo er hingehört die
kirche fängt um so unsere vielen dann
zur kirche gehen und dann man wusste wie
ein arbeitstag aussieht wie ein werktag
aussieht wie man sich anzuziehen hat
dann beerdigungen alles rituale also das
halbe leben war ritual und das halbe
leben war arbeit und beides war völlig
klar geregelt über jahrhunderte und es
war wie eine stehengebliebene zeit in
der nichts mehr geändert wurde
selbst lieder zum beispiel ich habe mich
immer gewundert wie haben diese lieder
mitgebracht bei der einwanderung vor 300
jahren
da ging nichts verloren und es kam aber
auch nichts dazu und das war sehr
seltsam und das war dieses man hat sich
konserviert man hat sich lebend
konserviert und immer angst gehabt vor
diesem assimiliert werden
wir sind ein kleiner haufen und wir
müssen und dass wir von der umgebung
nicht geschluckt werden und dafür hat
man diese versteinerung in kauf genommen
und also als ich mal nicht mehr auf dem
dorf lebt er als ich mit 15 in die stadt
kam und dann mann ins dorf zurück kam zu
meinen eltern ist mir das schon ziemlich
bezahlen vorgekommen
diese stehen gebliebene zeit dass dieses
dorf und nicht nur dieses all diese
dürfe wie eine kiste in der dagegen
steht und dass man auch die stadt hat
man verachtet will sich so gehört also
auch aus natürlich war das auch eine ein
komplex man hat sich natürlich im
stillen hat man schon gewusst dass es in
der stadt auch sehr viele dinge gibt die
beneidenswert sind und die man auf dem
dorf nicht haben kann aber dafür um das
zu kompensieren hat man da die stadt
gerast und hat sich nur abschätzig über
die stadt geäußert über das hochdeutsch
hysterisch also und der dialekt war das
ideale und insofern hat man sich
natürlich etwas auch durch durch
täuschung hat man sich für das bessere
gehalten um nicht nachdenken zu müssen
wir es wie es ist
aber ich habe schon als mädchen wenn man
wie man sie liest spürt man dass es
dinge gab für sie gesehen haben dass
diese ordnung dieser überschaubare
ordnung auch liste hat oder grauzonen zb
beschreiben sie doch dass es ihnen fast
unheimlich war ihre mutter beim
kartoffel essen zuzuschauen
ja also das geht ja irgend diese
deportation meine mutter war fünf jahre
deportiert im arbeitslager in der
heutigen ukraine von den sowjets und ich
habe immer den eindruck gehabt sie ist
es ist also schon als ich ein kind war
habe ich den eindruck gab sie ist als
ich übrigens auch ich habe auch gedacht
als kind ich bin alt und als ich so fünf
sechs jahre alt war habe ich schon
gedacht immer ich lebe schon so
wie kann man überhaupt sie ist jetzt
schon 26 wie kann man so lange neben wie
hält man das aus was macht man überhaupt
in der zeit ich habe schon fast alles
gemacht in sechs jahren
und wenn ich jetzt so alt werden soll
was mache ich denn in dieser ganzen das
heißt ich habe ein bisschen gegeben in
der zwischenzeit und umgekehrt
aber ja ich hatte den eindruck sie ist
alt und auch sie war ja nicht die
einzige im dorf waren ja alle in ihrer
generation deportiert die zu jung oder
zu alt für den krieg waren und sie war
natürlich beschädigt das habe ich als
kind nicht gewusst ich habe nur gesehen
dass sie so seltsam mehr eigenschaften
hat und das mit der kartoffel war das
eine so eine art sie hatte wie eine
komplizenschaft mit der kartoffel
auch wenn sie gegessen hat oder wenn ich
wusste kartoffeln schälen lernen ganz
dünn
die schale wie haut und nur in einer
schale dass die ganze kartoffelschälen
und sie hat auch keine innere ruhe
gehabt sie hat sich irgendwie nie freuen
können
ich habe nie gesehen dass meine mutter
wirklich glücksmoment er hatte das ich
habe das als kind nicht inhaltlich
gedeutet aber ich habe gespürt ich habe
die inhalte nicht verstanden und
deportation habe ich sowieso nicht
gewusst was das ist aber wenn sie dann
so sätze gesagt hat beim kämmen wie oft
sie kahl geschoren wurde im lager oder
dass ich mich immer zu dick anziehen
musste weil frieren ist schrecklich oder
wenn sie sagte durst tut mehr weh als
hunger wind ist kälter als als als der
schnee das war für mich dann das waren
schon sätze die die haben wehgetan
auch wenn ich nicht wusste
welche dimensionen dieser sätze haben
ich habe immer gespürt dass meine mutter
etwas mit sich herumschleppt es war ja
auch verboten darüber zu sprechen
aber die leute die deportiert waren
wussten natürlich voneinander dass sie
deportiert waren und haben auch wenn
auch nur in halbsätzen oder in
andeutungen
ständig darüber gesprochen weil sie alle
von dieser deportation natürlich auch
beschädigt waren
und es kamen immer wieder situationen wo
sie direkt auf diese schwere erinnerung
so zurückgeworfen wurden
und obwohl sie nicht jetzt explizit
darüber erzählten welchem alter wo du
ihn in dieser geschichte deutlich und
bewusst zu diese vergangenheit auch sie
haben mal ihr name vorname hat er
unmittelbar auch mit dieser geschichte
zu tun
ja meine mutter habt ihr eine freundin
im lager und ist verhungert und dann
hatte sie sich versprochen dass sie wenn
sie wieder kehrt werden sie überlebt und
wenn sie ein mädchen bekommt ein kind
bekommt das ein mädchen ist dass sie
diesem kind diesen namen gibt und daran
hat sie sich gehalten
insofern ist dieser gar nicht schöne
name trotzdem
also ich muss diesen namen sogar mit
wenn ich weiß woher er komme woher er
kommt und dass meine mutter dadurch auch
eine sehr beachtliche form freier
erinnerung geschaffen hat die natürlich
nicht mich belastet ich hab ja diese
frau nicht gekannt
es ist ja für sie muss ist ja doch
gespenstisch sein weil sie vielleicht
geht einem das mit den jahren verloren
aber sie muss ja doch immer wieder
vielleicht auch an zwei menschen denken
wenn sie wenn sie diesen namen
ausspricht
das kann ja nicht ganz einfach sein dass
sie sich das angetan hat ist ja okay ich
habe den eindruck in ihrer biografie
dass dann eine glückliche zeit kam im
lyzeum sprache schreiben ich habe in
einem zeitungsartikel gelesen dass
dieses lena lyzeum auch heute noch eine
gute brutstätte für literatur ist das
junge autoren auch da herauswachsen
das ein bisschen an ein falscher
eindruck das ist eine sehr auf es ist
ein bisschen aufgesetzt
also für mich war das lithium nicht so
wichtig in dieser hinsicht wichtig waren
vielleicht nicht die institution und ich
meine dieses unterrichtsprogramm das war
natürlich gar nichts das wagen sanierte
lehrbücher dort durch den nichts drin
sein was was der staat nicht zulassen
wollte wichtig waren glaube ich die
persönlichen dinge die dadurch
entstanden sind das heißt man hat
freunde getroffen und hat leute
kennengelernt gleichaltrige die
dieselben interessen hatten und dadurch
dass entstanden hier gruppen von
menschen von von jungen leuten die
anfänger bücher zu lesen
und das war vielleicht wichtig aber dass
das hat die schule nicht als institution
angestrebt oder ermöglicht oder sogar
befördert
die schule war wie jenseits davon auch
eine eine sehr stramme institution das
heißt uniformen kontrollen den ganzen
tag dann diese komischen
marxismus leninismus und in vielen
sitzungen und was weis ich freiwilligen
arbeitseinsatz und also das fand ich das
war das war überall so außerdem der
geheimdienst also wie man heute weiss
gab es in jeder klasse in dem alter
schon spitzel und die schüler würden
überwacht wir hatten am nummern auf
denen stand immer die nummer also die
schule und die nummer überall in der
stadt jeder schüler hatte seine nummer
überall in der stadt war man sofort
identifizierbar
wenn jeder auf der straße ein
unbekannter passant lust hatte oder den
eindruck hat der mann tut irgendetwas
was unerlaubt ist konnte er an dieser
nummer sofort ablesen wer man ist und
wie die schule benachrichtigen außerdem
wurden ständig schüler rekrutiert für
geheimdienste also auch erpresst vor zum
beispiel vor der matura vor der
reifeprüfung und es war also das gehört
alles zusammen
ich würde dieses sozialistische
schulsystem nicht idealisieren und da
spielte die deutsche schule hat aber
auch keine große ausnahme gespielt außer
dass wir natürlich in dieser sprache
lernen konnten
aber das hatten die ungarn auch in ihrer
in ihren schulen oder die serben haben
auch in ihrer in ihrer minderheit
sprache auf dem gymnasium lernen können
und der schuldirektor das weiß man heute
hat für den geheimdienst gearbeitet und
hat auch schüler rekrutiert mittels des
geheimdienstes durch erpressung und also
das sollte man nicht idealisieren und
zum schreiben kam man nicht wegen dieser
schule sondern haben leute getroffen man
hat sich persönlich für etwas
interessiert man hat angefangen zu lesen
und so kam auch ich auf die deutungen
der deportation
das hat er natürlich mit dem verstehen
dass der verstrickung in den
nationalsozialismus zu tun
mein vater war in der s
und ich hab dann erst verstanden dass
die minderheit war verstrickt in den
nationalsozialismus dann um sich im
namen der kollektivschuld an den
zerstörungen der nazis in der
sowjetunion wurden dann diese deutsche
deportiert aber sie haben natürlich nur
zivilisten genommen
der krieg war noch gar nicht zu ende
mein vater war noch gar nicht zuhause
aber sie haben meine mutter genommen
zivilisten die nichts angestellt hatten
und die wurden dann deportiert und so
habe ich dann auch durch das lesen über
konzentrationslager und über die
verstrickungen
das kam so natürlich durch alle
möglichen zusammenhänge dass auch dass
die neugierde darauf dann fingen wir an
bücher zu lesen
ich wollte wissen ich las dann ja auch
das aus der deutschen minderheit leute
auch konzentrationslager aufseher waren
ich hatte immer angst mein vater hat
eine ganz ganz schreckliche rolle
gespielt und wer weiß was er getan hat
und dann hat man diese bücher gelesen
dann hat man zählen gelesen
das kam ja auch aus der bukowina das
gehört ja auch zu rumänien hat ja auch
lange in bukarest gelebt und da hat man
natürlich sich das alles auf sich selbst
bezogen und gewusst
diese literatur bewohners du aber du
kommst von der anderen seite
du bist auf der seite der täter geboren
und das war ein problem
und dann kann man die 68er jahre in
deutschland verstrickungen die waren ja
immer mit der frage beschäftigt was hat
der einzelne in der elterngeneration
getan es für uns galt die gleiche
problematik
wir hatten auch eltern die wagen mit
hitler in der ss oder in der wehrmacht
oder mit antonescu rumänien war ja ein
faschistischer staat also es war fast
egal ob man in der zeit in der
rumänischen armee war mit antonescu war
man auch in spanien
hat oder man war die in der deutschen
armee also dieses die problematik betraf
uns alle und wir haben auch aus diesem
interesse heraus haben wir auch
angefangen bücher zu lesen das geht dann
bis zu thomas bernhard wo der tägliche
faschers faschistoide umgang in einem
land auch noch jahrzehnte später
thematisiert wird und so hat sich immer
das eine aus dem anderen ergeben und da
drückt er dann von von außen kam dieses
rumänischen staates als er als junger
dolmetscherin in dieser traktorenfabrik
gearbeitet haben und dann kommt diese
episode die man so unter dem titel des
dritten witzes definieren könnte weil
ihnen diese ganze komplexität von
kollaboration oder verteidigung der
eigenen identität des eigenen die
wahrheit gegen ein regime war in das zu
diesem zeitpunkt bewusst als ja auch
hätten rekrutiert werden sollen als man
mit ihnen plötzlich die brutalität auch
auch an ihnen hat spielen lassen kann es
gar nicht so genau sagen wie viel mehr
bewusst wahr oder nicht bewusst war
wenn man in einer situation gefangen ist
und bedroht wird man angst hat man denkt
da nicht in theoretischen kategorien
sondern da muss man sich verhalten und
verhalten ist ja was anderes das ist
intuitiv ich habe gewusst ich kann für
den geheimdienst nicht arbeiten
ich habe dieses regime körperlich so
geekelt ich habe den ganzen tag diese
nullen gesehen diese funktionäre diese
schwierigen analphabeten die die leute
schikanierten den ganzen tag in der
fabrik zum beispiel die sind viele leute
um vier uhr nachts aufgestanden in die
stadt gependelt haben den ganzen tag in
hundsmiserabel in betrieb
gestanden an den fließbändern haben
geschuftet in einer halle wo keine
glasfenster mit den scheiben mehr waren
wo es kalt war
man konnte nichts vernünftiges
produzieren also es war elendig und
diese typen haben die nur bewacht in den
sitzungen fertig gemacht und sie selbst
waren intellektuelle nullen und von den
humanen eigenschaften her waren sie auch
nur und richtig brutale emporkömmlinge
und also mich hat das so angeekelt diese
diese typen haben mich so angeekelt und
die haben sich in den sitzungen dermaßen
immer blamiert als als als menschen als
individuen planiert und insofern kam es
überhaupt nicht in frage für mich und
ich wusste ich kann das nicht machen
für mich war auch eine warnung dass mein
vater hinterher es war und ich habe
gedacht wenn ich ihm das vorwerfen dann
ich weiß ich lebe in einer diktatur und
ich kann es mir damit nicht einfacher
machen indem ich mich irgendwie
arrangieren
weil man wird mich das später fragen
und außerdem es wären wir wirklich gar
nicht möglich gewesen
ich habe mir gedacht sich da mit hinein
zu begeben und dann aussteigen zum
beispiel geheimdienstmitarbeiter das ist
komplizierter aussteigen ist immer
komplizierter als nicht nicht von anfang
an nein sagen
auf diese anderen seite die andere
alternative wäre ja auch hätte tot sein
können das beschreiben sie ja auch ja
das gibt es
das wird noch mal man wird bedroht das
passiert ja nicht alles wie wir es jetzt
wenn wir es jetzt lesen oder auch
darüber nachdenken dann entstehen ganz
große teile weil wir es zusammen denken
aber damals ist es ja im einzelnen
im winzigen detail passiert das heißt
jeden tag etwas insofern man erlebt es
dann anders man erlebt ist im fragment
im einzelnen aber dieses fragment ist
natürlich auch dann das ganze im erleben
weil man angst hat aber man sieht
trotzdem ich das ganze wenn man drin
steckt man tut nur das was in diesem
moment nötig ist
man schützt sich und auch wenn einem
gesagt wird wir werfen dich ins wasser
oder es gibt auch verkehrsunfälle ja
dann sagt man okay dann ist das so und
man hofft natürlich dass es nur
einschüchterung ist man glaubt es
natürlich aber nicht man hat ständig
angst und man muss sich mit der angst
arrangieren und man muss die angst ein
bauern ins leben
man muss die angst war und ins leben und
sie zu einem begleitenden bestandteil
aller anderen dinge machen die einen
mitten mit denen man es zu tun hat
und das funktioniert auch eine weile bei
ihnen waren ist ja mindestens 15 jahre
ich war dann auch kaputt als ich aus so
mehr weggegangen bin konnte ich das
lachen und das weinen nicht mehr
unterscheiden
also ich war mit den herren kaputt das
heißt auf ewig kann man diese diese
sachen nicht rational beherrschen
eine zeit lang schon und auch
verschieden also ich habe freunde gehabt
die sind sehr sehr viel früher als ich
zerbrochen nervlich zu blocken und haben
nicht viel ausgehalten dass er ist immer
wahrscheinlich konnte psychischen
strukturbedingt man weiß das nicht man
kann das nicht von außen sagen ich
glaube man weiß es nicht einmal von sich
selbst
und wenn es einem auch passiert ich habe
das auch erlebt dass leute wenn sie
kaputt gehen
nervlich dass sie das auch überhaupt
nicht merken
und wenn man in diese über diese grenze
hinweg getrieben wird man will das ja
auch nicht wahrhaben
und das schlimme ist dass man auch nicht
geschützt werden kann
also ich weiß wenn ich jetzt ein rolf
bossert denke der dann auf rumänien
verlassen hat und es war zu spät und hat
sich ja dann einen drei wochen nachdem
er das land verlassen konnte aus dem
fenster gestürzt und hat auch in
rumänien schon vorher suizid gedanken
gehabt und war ja auch im krankenhaus
weil man in den kieferknochen gebrochen
hat er wurde er mal zusammengeschlagen
im auftrag des geheimdienstes und man
hat den anscheinend im krankenhaus auch
mit psychopharmaka behandelt und man hat
dann auch gesagt jetzt soll er
auswandern denn er ist suizid gefährdet
und er soll das bitteschön im westen nun
also man hat das nicht verhindert
sondern man hat es beschleunigt und da
kann man auch mit freundschaft oder mit
nähe zueinander kann man solchen leuten
nicht auf
der lange abend dass der korrekte ging
ja auch bis nach deutschland und sie
beschreiben ja auch das ist bis heute
diese diese geschichte gibt und dass
diese menschen präsent sind ja die sind
in deutschland als ich aus deutsch aus
rumänien kam
ich habe es aber auch so erwartet die
die akte dies über sie gibt bevor wir
dann zum zu ihrem werk kommen es gibt 9
114 seiten lehrt jetzt nochmal 6
unterlag 1500 seiten akte christina wie
man es genannter drei bände ist dass
seine art wie ein parallel
werk zu ihrer existenz zu sein wächst ja
auch der existiert der biografie leben
nein das ist natürlich ein text aber das
ist das spiegelt natürlich mein leben
aus der sicht des geheimdienstes und in
diesem text sind natürlich sehr viele
lücken zum beispiel die fabrik kommt
überhaupt nicht vor
drei jahre sind nicht vorhanden warum
weiß ich nicht die zeit im westen wo ich
dann weiter bedroht wurde konnten auch
nicht vor
also das habe ich gehört das gehört
jetzt das ist wieder als geheim
eingestuft im heutigen rumänien weil man
sagt das ist geheimmaterial ich weiß
nicht warum ich stelle mir vor
wahrscheinlich beschäftigt man gewisse
agenten weiter und man will diese
agenten nicht verraten
und vielleicht würde man agenten
verraten denn die haben ja dann hier im
westen gespitzelt
und wenn man die weiter braucht zum
beispiel das wäre halt ein grund
vielleicht auch nicht für mich aber
vielleicht muss man wirtschaftsspionage
betreiben oder weiß nicht weiß ich was
für irgendwas wird man sie ja weiter
brauchen stelle ich mir vor das könnte
ein grund sein weshalb man diese akten
als immer noch als geheim eingestuft und
ich habe dann auch ja noch im westen in
deutschland todesdrohungen bekommen und
ich weiß jetzt auch aus meiner akte das
ist viele informanten gibt die auch und
das finde ich besonders verwerflich die
dieses land verlassen haben und dann
gingen sie in den sogenannten freien
westen und haben im westen weiter
gespitzelt und zwar gegen leute wie ich
jetzt und andere die dissidenten waren
oder die sich die dort schon einiges
riskiert hatten und also ich würde
wenigstens so viel anstand
verlangen dass man wenn man so eine
gesellschaft sein repressions stadt
verlässt das man dann wenigstens nicht
in dem anderen staat wo man dann von
allen dingen der verfassung der
menschenwürde profitiert dass man dann
wenigstens nicht mehr für einen
kriminellen geheimdienst aus dieser
freien gesellschaft weiter arbeitet das
finde ich besonders besonders infam
vielleicht sind wir jetzt schon fast
mitten drin in diesem buch die
atemschaukel sie zusammen mit oskar
pastior vorbereitet haben und über
längere jahre recherchiert haben
das buch das so überschattet werde die
ganze geschichte durch auch die akte
genau und gerade in jüngster zeit ja
dinge an die oberfläche kommen die ja
sicher extrem schmerzhaft sein müssen
weil genau dass es jetzt erzählt haben
auf einen ganz intimen freund ob sie ja
aber das ist ich glaube das ist ein
anderes eine andere sachlage
ich meine es ist natürlich für mich auch
erschreckend dass ich jetzt erfahre dass
oskar pastior für den geheimdienst
gespitzelt hat es ist trotzdem eine ganz
andere zeit also die 50er und 60er jahre
in rumänien das war stalin ismus die
gefängnisse waren voll mit auch
intellektuellen auch mit schrift stellen
es gab die schauprozesse die leute die
damals verhaftet worden waren alle wir
hatten klickten alle über 20 jahre in
der zeit hat oskar pastior diese
mitarbeiter unterschrieben und auch in
dem text in dem er unterschrieben hat
steht auch wegen er also als alternative
dazu wäre haft gewesen er wäre verhaftet
worden
und warum kam er überhaupt ins visier
er hat nach dem lager sieben gedichte
geschrieben über das lager zum thema
lage aufenthalt diese sieben gedichte
waren wurden von der
geheimdienst als anti sowjetische hetze
bezeichnet wegen diesen gedichten kam er
dann ins visier des geheimdienstes
kurz davor war eine frau verhaftet
worden die er denn der erdige dicht bei
der er sich versteckt hatte sie war so
naiv dass sich die gedichte vorgelesen
hat bekannten darunter waren spitze
sie ging sie sogar einbinden lassen zu
einem buchbinder
also das war mit den andererseits war
sie verhaftet worden da für sie kriegt
er dafür sieben jahre
gott sei dank musste sie nur zwei jahre
davon absitzen weil sich dann wieder die
verhältnisse etwas etwas gebessert
hatten spricht der von dem jetzt das was
der schwerste vorwurf ist lang pastor
der sich nachdem er vier jahre im
gefängnis gewesen war nachher das leben
genommen hat war schon verhaftet worden
kurz bevor zwei wochen bevor pastior
unterschrieben hat also passt er wusste
es ist nicht nur einschüchterung sondern
wenn er das nicht unterschreibt ist
nichts mehr da außer 20 jahre gefängnis
und das nach fünf jahren lage und ich
glaube er konnte sich das nicht fühlt
sich nicht er konnte das nicht aushalten
und der schwerste vorwurf der jetzt hier
in der öffentlichkeit herum welche
codiert wird unverantwortlicher weise
das passt ja angeblich auch am suizid
von hopp nicht schuld sein soll oder ihn
sogar ins gefängnis gebracht hat das
sind buchstäblich unverantwortliche
erfindungen als pastor seine mitarbeit
und unterschrieben hat war hab ich schon
im gefängnis
wir kennen die prozessakte von hobbys da
kommt der name stein ordner wie pastior
als informant ihn überhaupt nicht vor
also das ist wirklich durch durch
dokumente geklärt passt er hat mit der
verhaftung nichts zu tun und was nachher
kam das wissen wir nicht
aber ob ich hat nachdem er aus der aus
der haft kam keine anstellung mehr
gefunden er hat kein geld gehabt er hat
nicht mehr schreiben können
seine frau hat ein kind geboren das war
schwer krank und ist kläglich gestorben
nach mehreren operationen
das war alles furchtbar also alles was
mit rockig nach der haft passiert ist
ist in die katastrophe geschlittert und
zu sagen
castillo ist schuld also das ist ist
ungeheuerlich
und wie gesagt es waren diese zeiten
damals & paste dafür sich offenbar keine
andere wahl
und das hat mit mir ja nichts zu tun
ich war damals ein kind als das
passierte und darum glaube ich hat er es
auch nicht für nötig gehalten oder nicht
für möglich ich würde sagen für möglich
gehalten wir davon etwas zu sagen
er hat sich als er im westen ankommt zum
unterschied von den vielen spitze und
von denen wir vorher gesprochen haben
demi den hiesigen geheimdiensten restlos
anvertraut wie er sagt er hat die frau
die verhaftet worden war nicht seine
gedichte wegen sondern man hat ihr das
dann nur an gehängt weil sie sich
geweigert hatte spionage zu betreiben
gegen ihren bruder hat man dann diese
gedichte wieder hervor gezählt das geht
auch aus den akten hervor
er hat sich mit dieser frau im westen
aus eigener initiative sofort getroffen
also für ihn war die sache so weit
geklärt er hat den geheimdiensten gesagt
was wahr
er hat sich mit dieser frau getroffen
und hat versucht mit der das zu
besprechen was weiß ich klären was man
klären kann schuldig gefühlt hatte sich
ganz bestimmt auf alle fälle und damit
war für ihn die sache erledigt oder
nicht erledigt
er hatte sich mir gegenüber nicht zu
rechtfertigen er hat das schweigen
gelernt nur sexualität über das er nie
sprechen konnte jahrzehntelang dann das
lager über dass es verboten zu sprechen
jahrzehntelang und dann kam diese
geheimdienstmitarbeiter zu das ist
ich glaube er hatte sich die einsamkeit
des schweigens dermaßen verinnerlicht
dass er das gar nicht mehr anders konnte
gemeinsam und projekt über diese
deportation zeit ist es ja sehr
ergreifend wie körperlich eigentlich ihr
text wird wie sie wie sie eigentlich
eben sprachlosigkeit definieren die
plötzlich sich auch an dinge bindet
gegenstände objekte werden werden wieder
neu geschaffen bekommen eigene namen
bekommen eigene wörter zuordnungen und
die bleiben dann bedeutungsvoll für ein
ganzes leben diese präzision in der
literatur wo schreiben dann so etwas ist
wie überlebenshilfe und sie haben mal
gesagt dass sie ja selber auch nicht
gerne schreiben und das nicht leicht es
ist ja manchmal gesagt nur idioten
schreiben gerne das sagte nämlich immer
kalt ist das ist wahr
aber ich meine es ist natürlich eine
überlebenshilfe
aber was heißt das schon andere haben ja
auch geschrieben und es hat ihnen nicht
und ich geholfen nicht die nerven zu
verlieren
ich weiß nicht wie es wäre wenn man
nicht schreiben
das könnte ja sein es ist natürlich auch
immer eine große belastung weil ich muss
mich ja dann den dingen auch immer
wieder stellen
und weil sie sagen mit den gegenständen
ich meine in diesem buch in der
atemschaukel es war für passt ja so und
da habe ich auch gemerkt ich habe auch
damals
bei oskar pastior gemerkt wie fatal
diese plage beschädigung war dass das
wenn er mir dinge gezeigt hat zum
beispiel mit dem schaufeln dass das ist
das ist eine körperliche erinnerung gibt
also es gibt sachen und die sind
mindestens genau so hinterhältig wie die
die man als bewusst dass erinnern im
kopf herum trägt dass er wusste wie man
schaufelt wie man denke an der kraft
sparte dass er noch genau jede
zehenspitzen bewegung und verse und wo
man den einen fuß in den anderen hinter
und das habe ich ja dann in einem
kapitel beschämt aber so wie er es mir
gezeigt und er hat es mir immer im
ganzen gezeigt und wenn ich nicht mit
kam mit dem aufschreiben musste er das
ganze von vorne machen weil es ein
einziger ein einziger reflex war und
dass das war auch erschreckend oder er
sagt auch dass er alle paar nächte sein
ganzes leben hat vom lager ist einfach
egal wo er hinfährt in der nacht träumt
er und viel reiseverkehr gend wo alles
ändert immer im lager sie beschreiben
einmal die reise in dieses lag zusammen
mit passion 60 jahre danach und das
besucht hat sie beschreiben das fast
euphorisch in diesem moment wie jemand
der heimweg heimkehrt genau das war auch
so habe ich auch gemerkt dass eine
beschädigung ist eine ständige eine
unerträgliche unerträgliche bildung eine
beziehung die man die man nicht hergeben
kanzlei man sie braucht kehren sie denn
manchmal heim heim wo nach wo ja ich
fahre oft nach 12 mal im jahr
aber nicht time also in dem dorf aus dem
ich komme weiß ich noch nicht
seitdem ich ihn verlassen habe
ich war oft meistens in bukarest oder in
hermannstadt oder ich war in temesvar
aber nicht in dem dorf an ich nicht nein
und der begriff der versöhnung
was heißt versetzt dieser geschichte mit
dieser vergangenheit mit diesem ja womit
sollte ich mich von sehen
man kann sich doch nur mit einzelnen
dingen versöhnung auch ich weiß auch
nicht wie ich das tun sollte also mit
einem geheimdienst geheime nicht
versöhnen
es ist eine institution das ist der typ
der mich zum beispiel jahre lang verhört
hat das war ja meistens derselbe mit
einzelnen die dazu kam aber der der
kontinuierliche vernehmen dass ich habe
gehört es ist mittlerweile gestorben
der war schon 50er jahre also der war
schon alter wie man mal getroffen
ich habe auf der straße getroffen und
dann hat er sich in eine schlange
hineingestellt weil damals das war kurz
nach 1990 war das immer da waren die
leute noch sehr wütend auf den
geheimdienst und da sind geheimdienste
wenn man sie so erwischt hat auf der
stars ja auch noch und da hat er sich
schnell in eine schlange gestellt und ja
ich habe auch gar nicht gewusst was ich
sagen soll
ich habe ihn auch nicht erkannt gleich
ich habe ihn an seiner angst erkannt
denn er hatte die mitte auf und ich habe
ihn ja immer nur im büro gesehen da war
häufig oder wie sagt man und im jackett
und insofern ich habe nur erkannt weil
ich seine reaktionen gesehen habe seinen
schrecken und ich wusste auch gleich was
ich sagen soll
ich habe ihr nur gesagt sehen sie jetzt
müssen sie angst haben vor mir
oder wozu war das gut ich meine was
heißt auch versöhnen
ich will mich nicht versöhnen
was heißt es überhaupt also verstehen
könnte ich mich eventuell mit einer mir
nahe stehenden menschen mit dem man
streit hat und da geht es um irgendein
problem und ein thema und dann wird man
verletzt und man überlegt sich das und
die person sagt mir ich hab dich
verletzt
es tut mir leid oder umgekehrt ich habe
die person verletzt und ich sage es tut
mir leid dann könnten wir uns versöhnen
weil wir eine gemeinsamkeit haben aber
ich kann mich doch nicht versöhnen mit
mit einem geheimdienst oder mit einem
diktatorischen system
ich würde sie gerne eine letzte frage
fragen nämlich haben sie also ein
taschentuch mit dabei ein
papiertaschentuch hab ich ja das habe
ich dabei aber kein ich habe sehr viele
bücher bekommen
nach dieser rede haben wir sehr viele
leute geschrieben oder auch wenn ich bei
veranstaltungen war hat man die
taschentücher geschenkt
ich habe sogar einen sehr sehr rührenden
brief bekommen von einer frau die hatten
eine taschentuch fabrik und diese fabrik
ist offenbar schon ziemlich lange pleite
gegangen ja eben weil die taschentücher
nicht mehr als leide taschentücher nicht
mehr gekauft er regierte war möglich
dankt ihm herzlich für dieses gespräch
[Musik]
dieses gespräch scheint mir ein
zeitzeugnis zu sein
sie können das kaufen auf dvb die
adresse lautet wie immer schweizer
fernsehen redaktions sternstunden 80 52
zürich ihre e mail erreicht uns
unterstellen kopien ab sf.tv das
gespräch gibt es auch als podcast zum
herunterladen auf unserer website
nächste woche geht es hier in der
philosophie um ein gegensatzpaar um lärm
und um stille heute aber zeigen ihnen
noch diesen außergewöhnlichen film davon
träumt jeder obdachlose dass er eines
tages alle seine sorgen los wäre das ist
jung büro nagano passiert mehr noch er
ist als künstler zu späten ruhm gekommen
zuerst aber gibt es jemand kurz vor
zwölf noch eine prise frischfilm filme
die sie machen und wir auswählen senden
tun wir die besten aus der qual der wahl
nun folgender
[Musik]
hat das alles schon vorbei sein könnte
in dieser woche zwischen weihnachten und
neujahr waren sie beide vollkommen
glücklich
sie stießen an auch sich auf das kind
darauf dass sie eigentlich nicht wussten
wie alles weitergehen sollte sie lachten
und tranken und stießen wieder auf
irgendetwas an
sie hatten lange keine uhr mehr gesehen
manchmal klingelt das telefon
die kerzen brannten herunter floyd stand
auf um eine neue platte aufzulegen
sie hatten seine ganze sammlung durch
und begannen wieder von vorne mit hotel
california
er hatte nicht geahnt dass dieses glück
fürs ganze leben reichen musste
[Musik]
aufstieg aus der gasse hinauf zur
höchsten kunst wein was klingt wie ein
märchen ist möglich nicht oft aber es
geschieht eben doch jan bürli die ahnung
lebte im postkommunistischen rumänien
als totalverweigerer und klossa
konsequent gehaust hat er in einem
hinterhof inmitten von ratten und müll
bis ein kunstsinniger mensch durch
zufall auf den freiheitsliebenden penner
aufmerksam wurde und unter der dicken
schicht von verwahrlosung ein
hochkarätiges talent erst entdeckt und
schließlich frei gelegt hat jan bürli
diana nämlich verfügt über einen
unbestechlichen blick für
gesellschaftliche zustände und einen
präzis flinken umgang mit schere und
laien was dabei in einem früheren leben
schon herausgekommen ist sind collagen
die den vergleich mit den großen
chronisten der kunstgeschichte wie etwa
die bücher oder andy warhol nicht zu
scheuen brauchen
es klingt unglaublich und ist es auch
aber es ist wahr die geschichte des
wiederbelebten künstlers john b